- Un signe de la main chargé de
sens devant cet au revoir fode ,
dont des enfants, ont pu quitter
le complexe d'Azovstal
vers ce refuge temporaire.
Ici, on s'attend à accueillir
encore d'autres bus en
bombardée, où d'autres civils
sont toujours terrés.
Ces évacuations se déroulent
au moment où Marioupol
(explosion)
Les bombardements continuent,
signe que la trêve poure l'évacs
civils n'est pas respectée.
que nous le pouvons", indique
dent ukrainien,
Volodymyr Zelensky.
Il prév
diplomatique sera avorté
si la Russie tue d
qui peuvent être échangés
comme des prisonniers de gueés .
Il fait un lourd constat
de Marioupol, qui est passée de
ceci à cette ville complétement
la guerre se termine pour
ce soldat urkainien, blessé
par un tir de char.
forces russes pendant 17 jours,e
un soldat du camp adverse.
un des leurs, dit-il. Ils m'ont
demandé vec nous?'
Et j'ai repondu que je ne sais
plus ce que ce ter
Pendant ce temps, les force
russes poursuivent leur
offensive sur Marioupol, seloni.
"L'ennemi a repris
ses opérations visant à prendre
le contrôle de l'usine", dit-il.
un convoi de l'ONU est attendu
pour évacuer les derniers civils
réfugiés dans l'usine. Au total,
être évacuées de la villeassiég.
Ici Danielle Kadjo,